ah moi Ahmad tant de dames ont essayé
et échoué alors attachez une selle et Sid l'
étalon mais je veux tout partager
avec vous tu es le vent sous ma fuite
les algues de mon oeil seras-tu je
vais t'arrêter là  Je
romps avec toi
quoi mais j'ai planifié tout notre avenir notre
mariage nos enfants notre terrain funéraire tu
fais es-tu fou
nous n'avons eu qu'un jour ça a duré 40
minutes oui mais j'avais l'impression que 20 ah je
ne peux pas  bague je veux dire j'aime la bague mais
non je ne peux pas
tu es trop collant comment est ce collant
Luke
je n'arrive pas à y croire
visiteurs nous n'avons jamais eu de visiteurs
quelqu'un me pince bien devrais-je
te dire d'attendre c'est nous deux  est-ce que je
me suis cogné la tête qu'est-ce qui se passe ici j'espère vraiment
que ce n'est pas un rêve ce mec pour de
vrai
quoi que ce soit oh bien bonjour beau
je suis Brooke c'est Oh une structure osseuse si exquise
une mâchoire si forte j'ai des
papillons et des nausées
bonjour oh  bonjour les mammifères salut buck salut bye
buck et nouvelle aide oh droit sur le
massacre tout à fait inutile mais total  y fait mal
attends ce demi-collation est un
murmure de dinosaure et un danseur de salsa expert oui
ici il est le maître de la méditation le
suprême serein le quatre fois
champion des pensées lourdes du monde des
lectures mammifères le shangri-la ma on se verra
maintenant ça  est le gars qui va nous sauver
nouveau sujet
nous sommes tous sur le point de bien mourir ce n'est pas
bon le stress est un tueur desserrons nos
membres et ouvrons nos esprits vers le bas chien Oh
sérieusement j'attendrai j'ai tout le temps dans le
poulet funky du monde  bouncing betty
purée de pommes de terre hey Johnny pourriez-vous
m'aider s'il vous plait
mon nez est dangereusement proche de mes fesses
Je vais attraper l'équipage le
poste votre râteau ha ha ha c'est un jeu de mots je fais un
clin d'œil sous le cache-œil une mère
pleure une demoiselle en détresse pressentant
les vrais der de mon un tel gâchis
pourquoi les détectives un manque de respect pour
tout ça  trésors et cher je suis les
princes  s protecteur de ce monde perdu
mais mes amis m'appellent noir les gars bien joués
j'ai un message mais c'est le
retour bienvenu que vous avez volé la la la la la
la vous savez que je vais donc W hater vous
peut-être la classe jurassique fantastique Robi aller
figure
oh aime ce gros
qu'est-ce que tu fais buck tous les rochers raconte une
histoire ouais où nous avons été et où
nous nous dirigeons ah c'est cependant une merde l'a
trouvé voici les mammifères un aperçu
de l'astéroïde à venir un rocher spatial
frais de  le cosmos mmm
j'ai un goût de fer carbone oh et un soupçon de
nickel hein l'
espace a un goût de solitude Hey regarde j'ai trouvé
un autre espace me rock aussi Hey le
tien est attiré par moi non le tien est
attiré par moi oh nous sommes juste trop
attirants